♪
>> Greg: BEAUTIFUL.
BEAUTIFUL, BEAUTIFUL.
HAPPY THURSDAY, EVERYBODY.
ALL RIGHT, CONTROL YOURSELVES.
MY GOODNESS.
I'M NOT JUST A PIECE OF MEAT.
SO I THINK WE'RE FINALLY
REALIZING THE SECRET TRUTH ABOUT
THE WOKE, THAT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY BELIEVE IN
THIS GAR BEIGE IS LIKE BRIAN
KILMEADE'S FAN BASE.
WAY SMALLER THAN WE THINK.
IT'S TRUE.
WE ALWAYS ASSUME THE WOKE HAVE
THE NUMBERS.
BUT WE REALLY, WE NEVER REALLY
KNEW HOW MANY.
WAS IT 10 MILLION?
ONE MILLION?
WHAT IF IT'S JUST 500 MISERABLE
NARCISSISTS?
WHAT IF IT'S JUST KEITH
OLBERMANN?
THE HILL REPORTS ON A NEW STUDY
WHICH SHOWS PEOPLE OFTEN APPEAR
MORE POLITICALLY EXTREME THAN
THEY REALLY ARE JUST TO FIT IN.
OF COURSE, THERE ARE SOME
EXCEPTIONS LIKE ANTIFA, ISISAND
THE CAST OF THE VIEW.
BUT THE POPULAR REPORT COMPARE
HOW MUCH PEOPLE AGREE WITH
POLITICAL STATEMENTS ON PUBLIC
TO THEM WHEN REVISED IN PRIVATE
AND THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
STATED AND PRIVATE OPINIONS WERE
AS BIG AS MY QUADS.
THEY'RE BIG.
YOU'LL SEE THEM LATER.
THAT'S A TEASE.
FOR EXAMPLE, IT TURNS OUT
MILLENNIALS WHO TEND TO BE
PROGRESSIVE ARE MUCH MORE
CONSERVATIVE WHEN IT COMES TO
EDUCATION.
WHY?
BECAUSE NOW THEY HAD KIDS WHICH
MEANS THEY DON'T THINK IT'S
ALREADY FOR A TEACHER TO SHOW
SECOND GRADE STUDENTS HOW TO
TWERK.
YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL THEY'RE
IN 5TH GRADE LIKE MINE DID.
MEANWHILE 74% BELIEVES PARENTS
SHOULD HAVE MORE CONTROL OVER
THE CURRICULUM.
THAT'S A DIFFERENCE OF 26 POINTS
COMPARED TO THEIR PUBLIC
OPINION.
THAT'S MORE POINTS THAN JIMMY
FAILLA HAS ON HIS DRIVER'S
LICENSE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: NOW THIS SHOULD
ACTUALLY PISS YOU OFF.
IT MEANS THESE GENERATIONS MASS
CA RAID TO FIT IN RATHER THAN
STEP UP.
IN SHORT THEY HAVE LESS BACKBONE
THAN A BUCKET OF SNAILS.
IT'S THIS COWARD IS THAT ENABLES
SUCH TERRIBLE IDEAS TO PERSIST.
IT'S WHY I GET PISSED OFF WHEN I
SEE FOLKS STILL WEARING MASKS
OUTSIDE:  THEY'RE KEEPING A MYTH
ALIVE PLUS IT KEEPS ME FROM
SPITTING GUM INTO THEIR MOUTHS.
I LEARNED THAT FROM MY MOM.
I'M GLAD PEOPLE WITH CRAZY WOKE
IDEAS AREN'T REALLY CRAZY WOKE
AT ALL.
BUT DOES IT REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IF THE PEOPLE CALLING
ME A NAZI ARE JUST TRYING TO
MAKE FRIENDS?
FOR EXAMPLE, THEY HAVE WAY MORE
PRIVATE DOUBTS ABOUT RACISM AND
GENDER IDEOLOGY BEING TAUGHT IN
SCHOOL.
THAT'S BIG.
MEANING THE LEADING CAUSE OF
STUPIDITY IS BECAUSE IT'S COOL.
WOULD YOU HAVE KNOWN THAT IF NOT
FOR THIS SURVEY?
YOU'RE WELCOME, AMERICA.
YOU'D HAVE TO ASK PEOPLE IN
PRIVATE ABOUT THEIR BELIEFS, AND
THEY MIGHT NOT TELL.
SO THAT MEANS WHILE THEY MIGHT
AGREE WHEN YOU'RE ALONE, THEY
MIGHT NOT STAND WITH YOU IN A
SCHOOL BOARD MEETING.
THEY'RE LIKE THAT GUY IN THE
TITANIC WHO THREW ON A LADY'S
WIG SO HE COULD BOARD THE LIFE
BOAT FIRST.
REMEMBER THAT FELLOWS, ALWAYS
BRING A WIG WHEN YOU GO ON A
CRUISE.
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS.
IT ALSO TURNS OUT THAT THOSE
UNDER 30 REJECT MORE THAN JUST
MY FRIEND REQUESTS.
UNLIKE THEIR PUBLIC PERSONAS,
THEY DON'T WANT CEOS TO
PONTIFICATE ON SOCIAL ISSUES AND
THEY DON'T BELIEVE RACISM IS
BUILT INTO AMERICAN LIFE.
AGAIN THAT'S HEARTENING BUT ALSO
INFURIATING.
MARRIAGE IF THESE COWARDS HAD
BALLS, THEN WE MIGHT NOT HAVE
HAD RIOTS OR LOOTING OR CRIME
WAVES OR EVEN BETTER DEMOCRATS
IN POWER.
IF THESE [BLEEP]s STOOD UP
AGAINST THE TINY THRONG OF
MISERABLE EXTREMIST ON CAMPUS OR
SOCIAL MEDIA, AMERICA WOULD BE
GREAT.
I'D TELL THEM TO GROW A PAIR BUT
THAT MEANS SOMETHING TOTALLY
DIFFERENT THESE DAYS.
IT'S TRUE T SADLY, THEY'RE ONLY
HONEST WITHIN THEIR OWN CRANIAL
CRAWL SPACE.
AND IT'S THERE THAT THEY'RE LESS
LIKELY TO FAVOR SPEECH CODES OR
FORCE PEOPLE TO WEAR MASKS.
BUT THAT'S MEANINGLESS BECAUSE
IT'S PRIVATE.
YOU'VE GOT TO LET THAT STUFF
OUT.
THIS IS THE U.S., IT'S NOT IRAN,
FOR CHRIST'S SAKES.
WELL, NOT YET ANYWAY.
BUT THIS IS PUBLIC LYING THAT
CREATES AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE
WOKE EXERCISE UNDESERVED
AUTHORITY AND WHERE EVERYONE
ELSE LIES TO AVOID BEING
OSTRACIZED LIKE FOX AND FRIENDS
HOSTS.
HALF OF AMERICANS ADMIT AVOID
SAYING SOMETHING FOR FEAR OF
UPSETTING JACKASS.
I LIVE UPSETTING JACKASSES
THAT'S WHY I BOUGHT THE
BILLBOARD OUTSIDE NPR.
NO WONDER NO ONE TRUSTS ANYTHING
ANYMORE BECAUSE IF YOU'RE LYING
YOU KNOW EVERYONE ELSE IS LYING,
TOO.
THE WOKE TOLD US ALL INTO THE
CLINTONS.
WORSE WE'RE LIKE THE AUDIENCE
MEMBERS OF THE VIEW NERVOUSLY
AGREEING THAT  ANNA NAVARRO
SEEMS SMAFRMENT WE'RE NOW IN
TRIBES THAT WE DON'T EVEN
BELIEVE IN.
IT'S AN IDIOTIC THOUGHT THAT THE
MOST EXTREME POSITION IS NOW
CONSIDERED THE SAFEST POSITION
PUBLICLY.
IT'S LIKE PEER PRESSURE IS
TURNING US INTO A BUNCH OF EVEL
KNIEVELS.
>> DYLAN WE LIKE YOU YOU DON'T
HAVE TO DO THIS EXTREME STUFF TO
FIT IN.
YOU KNOW I THINK SETTING
YOURSELF ON FIRE IS STUPID.
>> YOU'RE NOT GOING TO END UP IN
THE RECORD BOOKS.
MORE LIKELY END UP IN THE
HOSPITAL.
SO YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DO IT,
OKAY?
PROMISE?
OKAY.
CRAZY.
[SCREAMING].
>> OH.
>> YOU KNOW, I NEVER LIKED HIM
ANYWAY.
>> YEAH, ME NEITHER.
>> Greg: APPLAUD A FIERY DEATH.
YOU MONSTERS.
AND SO WITH DISHONEST MEDIA
ALONG WITH TWITTER BLUE CHECK
NARCISSIST AND ACTIVISTS WHO
HAVE ART WITH FOOD HAS EVERYONE
HIDING BEHIND EXTREME BELIEFS.
TIME WE START RUINING THEIR TRUE
ART WHICH IS LYING BUT NOT
THROWING MASHED POTATOES OR SOUP
AT THEM BUT THE TRUTH BECAUSE
NEVER IN HISTORY HAS SO LITTLE
DONE SO MUCH HARM TO SO MANY AND
TELLS YOU WHY ONCE AGAIN THIS
SHOW IS NUMBER ONE AND STEPHEN
COLBERT IS NUMBER TWO.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> PERIOD!
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
THIS FIRST GUEST CAN SPOT A HOAX
STRIKING FEAR IN FAKE HATE CRIME
HOAX.
AUTHOR OF FAKE CRIME HOAX, DR.
WILFRED REILLY
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: PEOPLE CAN'T TAKE THEIR
EYES OFF HIM OUT OF FEAR HE'LL
STEAL THEIR WALLET.
HOST OF FOX ACROSS AMERICA,
JIMMY FAILLA!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SHE HATES HAUNTED
HOUSES 'CAUSE THE MONSTERS GET
ALL THE ATTENTION.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: AND THIS HALLOWEEN HE'S
HANDING OUT BEATINGS, MY MASSIVE
SIDE KICK AND THE NWA'S WORLD
CHAMPION TYRUS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SO PROFESSOR, WELCOME
TO THE SHOW IT'S YOUR FIRST
TIME.
I'M A FAN OF YOUR WORK.
YOU CAME OUT WITH THIS AMAZING
BOOK ON HATE CRIMES AND I'M
ALWAYS AMAZED THAT YOU HAVEN'T
BEEN CANCELLED, ESPECIALLY WITH
YOUR PERFORMANCES ON TWITTER
WHICH ARE OFTEN INCREDIBLY
PERCEPTIVE AND YOU TAKE A LOT OF
RISKS.
HOW COME YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
CANCELLED?
IS THIS STUDY EXPLAINING THAT
THAT MAYBE MORE PEOPLE AGREE
WITH YOU THAN WE THOUGHT.
>> Wilfred: FIRST LET ME SAY YOU
MENTIONED THIS IN PASSING BUT
THE JACKASS IS PROBABLY THE BEST
SYMBOL EVER FOR A POLITICAL
PARTY SO I WANTED TO DROP THAT.
THERE'S PROBABLY A LOT OF
REASONS I HAVEN'T BEEN
CANCELLED.
BEING BLACK MAKES IT HARDER TO
CALL ME A NAZI, DOWN ON THE
LINE.
>> Tyrus: NOT AS HARD AS YOU
THINK BRO.
>> Wilfred: I FEEL YOU BROTHER.
THEY STILL TRY IT NO MATTER HOW
RIDICULOUS.
BUT AT ANY RATE I THINK THERE
ARE A COUPLE REASONS.
ON THE WALK FRONT I'VE READ THIS
STUDY BEFORE, PEOPLE CAN CHECK
THAT OUT MOST SERIOUSLY MOST RAN
IN THE HILL AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY
FASCINATING.
76% OF PEOPLE ACROSS LEFT AND
RIGHT THINK PARENTS SHOULD MAKE
MOST DECISIONS FOR THEIR KIDS.
ONLY 42% OF MILLENNIALS THINK
THE COUNTRY'S RACIST THAT CUTS
ACROSS BLACKS AND WHITES.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY ENTERTAINING.
THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE ARE
PRETTY NORMAL.
AND LAST THING, BUT THIS IS A
REVERSAL OF SOMETHING WE ALREADY
KNEW.
WE ALREADY KNEW PEOPLE TONED
DOWN THOSE CRAZY TRIBAL BELIEFS
WHEN THEY'RE IN MIXED COMPANY
ACROSS POLITICAL RACIAL LINES.
THIS IS THE REVERSE.
IF ALL YOU HANG AROUND WITH IS
PEOPLE JUST LIKE YOU YOU SAY THE
CRAZIEST IMAGINABLE STUFF TO FIT
IN AND LEAVE.
BUT THIS IS GOOD BECAUSE WE NOW
KNOW VERY FEW TRUE BELIEVERS
EXIST.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
TO ME IT'S REASSURING.
IT MAKES ME SAD THAT I MIGHT
HAVE BELIEVED IN THIS DELUSION
JIMMY -- IT'S WEIRD DO YOU HANG
AROUND WITH PEOPLE LIKE YOU?
THE HOMELESS SHELTERS ARE
BASICALLY THE CLOSEST YOU'LL
FIND.
>> Jimmy: AS LONG AS WE'RE NOT
WITHIN 500 FEET OF A SCHOOL I
CAN HANG OUT WITH AS MANY PEOPLE
LIKE ME ACID A HE LIKE.
>> Greg: DOES THIS STUFF
SURPRISE SNUB.
>> Jimmy: NO.
I ALWAYS BELIEVED THERE WAS A
GAP BETWEEN WHAT PEOPLE BELIEVED
PUBLICLY AND PRIVATELY ONLY
BECAUSE HOW WE'VE CHANGED
LABELING.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
WE TOOK DISAGREEMENT
RECHARACTERIZED IT AS HATE
SPEECH AND PUT A LOT OF PRESSURE
ON PEOPLE TO PLAY ALONG WITH THE
GROUP.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
SOMETHING VERY SIMPLE.
IF YOU SUPPORT VOTER ID YOU
SHALL A NOW CONSIDERED JIM CROW
ON TER VOIDS OR IF YOU WANT TO
TAKE A KID TO A STRIP CALL
YOU'RE NOW CONSIDERED A DEMOCRAT
SCHOOL TEACHER.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
BUT YOU GET IT.
AND WHAT WE'VE DONE IS, NOT ONLY
DOES IT HURT POLITICAL DEBATE
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY HURT THE
COUNTRY AND A GOOD EXAMPLE OF
THAT FOR REAL WOULD BE THE WALL.
DEMOCRATS VOTED FOR BORDER WALL
FUNDING TWICE BEFORE TRUMP CAME
DOWN THE ESCALATOR AND SAID
BUILD A WALL ASK AND NOW IT'S
RACIST WHICH IS PSYCHOTIC
BECAUSE EVERYONE'S GETTING INTO
THE BORDER.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENED IS WE EXPOSED
THE TYRANNY OF THE MINORITY JUST
IN TIME BECAUSE SOCIAL MEDIA
ALLOWED THEM TO WEAPONIZE BAD
IDEAS QUICKLY.
THE ONLY REASON WE DIDN'T DEFUND
THE POLICE AFTER BIDEN GOT
ELECTED BECAUSE HE THINKS
THEY'RE A BRITISH ROCK BAND BUT
IF IT WASN'T FOR THAT WE'D BE
SCREWED.
>> Greg: I GET THAT JOKE.
>> Jimmy: THERE YOU GO.
>> Greg: HEY KAT, HOW'S IT
GOING?
>> Kat: IT'S GOING SO WELL.
>> Greg: I'M VERY OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT THIS BUT I WONDER DOES
THIS MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE AT ALL?
LIKE DOES IT MATTER THAT THE
PERSON CALLING YOU A NAZI
DOESN'T REALLY MEAN IT?
>> Kat: NO.
I WISH WE COULD GO BACK TO THE
GOOD OLD DAYS WHERE PEOPLE
STOPPED HATING ME FOR WHERE I
WORK AND START HATING ME FOR WHO
I AM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Kat: THANKS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Kat: I'M NOT SURE IF THAT'S
GOOD OR NOT.
>> Greg: THEY APPLAUDED SOMEBODY
SET ON FIRE
>> Kat: YEAH, I DON'T KNOW.
LIKE THE TRUE BELIEVERSES,
YOU'LL NEVER TRULY WIN AND
BECAUSE I AM A TRULY HORRIBLE
PERSON I SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON
REDDIT AND THERE'S LIKE THE
BACHELORETTE AND EVERY DAY
THEY'RE CANCELLING ONE OF THE
CONTESTANTS FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THEY FOLLOW A REPUBLICAN OP
INSTAGRAM.
OR THEY LIKED A REPUBLICAN'S
TWEET.
AND IT'S LIKE, IF THIS IS WHAT
YOU EXPECT FROM YOUR REALITY TV
SHOW CONTESTANTS, YOU CAN'T BE
TOLERABLE, YOU CAN'T BE OUT
THERE IN THE REAL WORLD GETTING
ALONG WITH REAL PEOPLE.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE NEVER GOING TO
LIKE YOU ANYWAY SO IT'S TIME FOR
EVERYONE TO STOP SUCCEEDING UP
TO PEOPLE WHO CLEARLY SUCK AND
HAVE SAD CLUEDED EXPECTATIONS
ABOUT THE WORLD.
>> Greg: I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU
TYRUS WHAT THE SOLUTION WOULD BE
AND THE IDEA THAT IT'S EASY TO
SAY, DO NOT TAKE THESE PEOPLE
SERIOUSLY.
BUT IF LET'S SAY YOUR BOSS TAKES
THEM SERIOUSLY, OR YOUR HR
DEPARTMENT TAKES IT SERIOUSLY,
YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
LIKE, FOR EXAMPLE, THE EXAMPLE
THIS YOUNG LADY JUST USED.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME AGAIN?
>> Kat: I'M YOUNG!
>> Greg: LIKE A BACHELOR COULD
LOSE HIS --.
>> Tyrus: COULD HAVE.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Tyrus: WELL, THE TIMING OF
THIS COULDN'T BE ANYMORE
SUSPECT.
LOOKS LIKE THE WOKE SOIREE IS
OVER AND NOW RECEIPTS ARE GOING
TO BE HANDED OUT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Tyrus: THEY JUST LOST 534 OF
THEIR WOKE MEMBERS AT TWITTER SO
THERE'S GOING TO BE A HUGE
DROP-OFF ON THE HATE.
AND CEOs AND YOUR BOSSES AND
STUFF, DURING THE OZ PERIOD
WHERE THE CURTAINS AND SMOKE AND
BOTS MADE IT LOOK LIKE THEY HAD
HUGE NUMBERS BUT EVERY TIME I
GOT A WOKE PROTEST IT WAS LIKE
THREE PEOPLE AND ONE PERSON WITH
A REALLY LOUD MEG PHONE THAT
WERE THE WORST REPRESENTATIONS
OF WHATEVER THEY WERE TRYING TO
REPRESENT.
SO WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW IS THE
JIG IS UP, THE BLUE CHECK IS ON.
ELON CAME IN WITH A SINK WHICH
MEANS, I GET IT, HE'S THROWING
OUT EVERYTHING AND BRINGING HIS
OWN KITCHEN SINK.
GO BROKE WITH WOKE.
SO YOU'RE SEEING, HOW DO WE DO